[Musique]
le département de la réunion fêté ce
week-end les journées européennes du
patrimoine
les artistes ont investi les divers
sites culturels de la collectivité le
projet ico nomades du plasticien lionel
lorette a ravi le public du kerveguen à
saint pierre point d'orgue à cet
événement l'exposition résonances avec
les oeuvres du musée du louvre qui
seront visibles jusqu'au 15 octobre au
musée de villèle au muséum d'histoire
naturelle et au musée léon dierx
cette manifestation journées du
patrimoine c'est une manifestation
importante attendue par république
puisque c'est le moment où ils peuvent
aussi se donner une bonne raison de
sortir pour découvrir le patrimoine
réunis et dans son patrimoine
le département a quand même plusieurs
sites patrimoniaux
qui sont quand même très conséquent je
parlais du lazaret de la grande chaloupe
du musée de villèle après on a aussi sur
saint denis le musée léon dierx le musée
d'histoire naturelle l'arc de tête on a
aussi nos archives départementales donc
on a énormément de sites patrimoniaux
qui méritent vraiment que les
réunionnais fasse le déplacement pour
aller les découvrir et et voir tout ce
qu'il ya de mieux comme oeuvres
qui sont exposés
donc là nous raison d'un projet urbain
qui connaît mal les issues d'une
résidence que mal à faire du conatel
qu'il faudra taxer un petit peu les
arrache numérique depuis dix ans anaïs
top les archives toutes les photos les
textes
relatifs à l'océan indien à l'hypothèque
normal j'étais passionné une seconde
image du coup mal à proposer un tel
travail pour vivre après le banc amener
en contentieux ne bouge un peu les
images l'idée de sites et de mettre
certains à disposition un petit peu mais
asif
pour fait rentrer les gens dans un
plongeant la jambe voyage dans le passé
sur donc mal à travailler avec des
photos anciennes des photos de toutes
les époques finalement que la
constituent la réunion des images des
illustrations des gravures et mon
travail de mettre en place un petit soft
et bouge tout cela pour créer l'ambiance
est que dans une ambiance nous retrouver
un petit peu notre assise dans ce projet
là s'appelle importants que moi c'est
que on a la chance finalement d'avoir
cette ses racines de la culture elle est
par contre la tendance à oublier en fait
de monicault n'ai pas souvent des images
là donc c'est des images de l'époque que
la fournée la renault vraiment
et comme voilà la tête des personnages
des ans s'est tué sur les photos sur les
gravures baisse et nous mêmes en
vraiment bonne tête et ça l'est vraiment
impressionnant et du coup on pense que
c'est cette notion de fiat est
finalement que ce que l'on attendait
sont pliés
quand on voit la beauté finalement de
ceux de séance et ne souhaitons pas
oublier que nous défendons les beaux et
donc si cette beauté vous voulez mettre
en contact en fait ces images beauté des
ancêtres et nous mêmes un peu l'émission
bonjour bon je m'appelle henri maillot
je suis sculpteur mais comme vous le
savez au moins pour moi le dessin
précède possède toujours la sculpture
voilà donc j'enlève mon masque parce que
c'était quand même ici toujours une
période un peu compliquée souvenez vous
si en 2019 qu'on nous avait dit vous
savez quoi des amis l'année prochaine
vous allez porter un masque que vous
serez une confiné ne pourrait pas sortir
de chez vous ou alors on vous demandera
une autorisation spéciale pour savoir où
vous allez ce que vous faites c'est et
on n'y aurait pas cru et pourtant c'est
arrivé et donc ensuite de cela
comme c'était une période que je pense
historique car j'ai décidé de faire au
jour le jour un dessin pour montrer pour
dire un peu parce que je ressentais
pendant ce confinement ce qui a donné
lieu à une série de 49 49 des singes qui
correspondent à 49 jours si le
confinement avaient duré 300 jours
j'aurai paye 300 dessins donc la
première étape
de qualité de faire ce dessin là ils ont
été exposés les dernières la friche du
port et
l'invitation de deux du conseil
départemental nam nam nam chane kune qui
m'a proposé d'exposer certains dessins
parce qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
on ne pouvait pas tous les montrer en
raison du ciel du bâtiment à ciel ouvert
donc nous avons fait une sélection et
c'était vraiment fait la proposition
était vraiment intéressante parce que
d'une certaine manière ça renouer avec
avec la vocation
du site qui était injuste de confinement
et profitons aussi de cette journée du
patrimoine pour aller découvrir
l'exposition résonances c'est une belle
exposition qu'on a mis en place avec un
partenariat état et avec le musée du
louvre c'est une occasion unique pour
pouvoir cette exposition sur plusieurs
sites des musées de france de réunion et
j'incite tout à chacun à vraiment se
déplacer et à les voir et s'ils ne
connaissent pas et baptisé avec de la
première fois mais surtout qu'ils
n'hésitent pas à amener leurs amis et
surtout nos enfants parce que notre
patrimoine c'est notre richesse et il a
besoin est et relais est passé ce
patrimoine passée la connaissance de ce
patrimoine à l'ensemble de ma jeunesse
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
maîtriser notre histoire c'est apprendre
à mieux se connaître pour mieux se
protéger dans se projeter dans la
première
[Musique]